thank you for coming today to this
masturbatory display of political
theater yep all right who can ask the
stupidest question what exactly is
Facebook did everybody bring props
I believe the Constitution generally
applies to government yeah I love a
certain kind of chocolate relevant your
User Agreement sucks your budget sucks
do you have any idea how many of your
users actually read the Terms of Service
probably more than the amount of
congressmen who read the budgets they
pass and even if they read it they may
not understand it no [ __ ] I'm a lawyer I
have no idea what that means
but I bet you'd still vote for it
mumbles how many apps are there is it an
alternative to Facebook in the private
sector the rest of the Internet
second-rate wilford brimley go you are
hurting people you are bombing countries
congressmen meat sweat go Congress is
good at two things doing nothing and
overreacting Oh in spending there's
three things Diane what should Facebook
do take millions of Americans personal
information without their knowledge
Jesus I hate this place
the NSA already does that that's
alarming you let it happen
are you angry about that yes you're
upset about this we're upset about this
are you pre obvious to me that someone
is is listening to the audio on on our
phone you voted for that is no one
reading any of the bills at all small
head big shirt go honey it's more quaint
lowland and feel free to use that name
smajo picture how do I keep that from
happening is there settings within the
app that I need to go to to set to block
all that you set your shirt for medium I
just googled ant or I just put on your
website andrew Kinzinger he looks a lot
like me to be fair you look like every
quarterback who peaked in high school
you are tracking everything
no you're tracking everyone low rent
meat loaf I don't want to be
any information on me yeah it's creepy
Chappaquiddick jr. you've seen that with
in a foreign actor Cumberbatch budget
Matlock I'm a little disappointed in
this year and today I agree what do we
tell our constituents given what's
happened here I think you should just
apologize yeah you know what let me let
me just announce I will not be seeking
re-election next term do you believe
you're more responsible with millions of
Americans personal data than the federal
government would be yes
[Music]